- Une ville fantôme. Malgré
mesures sanitaires, les rues
de Pékin o r rarement été autant
désertes. Quatre jours après la
fin de la politique officielle
de contaminations a explosé.
Déjà 1 10 % de la population
est contaminée, selon plusieurs
estimations. Les autres restent
chez eux de peur de l'attraper.
sont devant les pharmacies,
où les gens font la queue
de dépistage, seul moyen de
connaître son état depuis la fin
Cet d dame dit avoir été
dans plusieurs pharmaciese e e ,
mais sans succès.
Cet homme se désespère
en raison de son mal de gorge.
Terminée, aussi, l'application
Anti-COVID, qui permettait
d'avertir en cas d'exposition.
Officiellement, le nombre
de nouvelles inf
en baisse. mais dans ce contexte
où l'on neeseste plus,
les chiffres officiels
ne veulent
NATHALIE GRANDVAUX, Département
biochimie et méd. moléc., eMeM
- Je pense que c'est ça qui va
nous donner e e petite idée de
comment ça va se traduire dans
la population.
- Seloiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqi,
la levée soudaine
des restrictions risque
de causer plus d'un million
et demi de mors de 6 millions ds
aux soins intensifs.
En cause : le faible taux de
vaccination des personnes âgées.
Moins des deux tiers des chino
vaccinés deux fois.
20 % seulement ont reçu
une troisième dose.
- Ce serait vraiment
optimiste their... Cent fois
faire face à une vag
sévère.
la fin de la politique
COVID-zéro est bien reçue.
"Cela ne sert à rien
de s'inquiéter. Il suffit
de Pékin.
A Wuhan, où l'épidémie
a débuté, c'est vécu
comme une libération.CeCeCeCeCes
que cela dure", dit ce jeune
homme de 24 ans. "Poursuivre le
confinement nous aurait obligé
à passe
à la maison."
Mais le retour à la vie normale
en Chine n'est pas pour demain.
Surtout qu'avec la fin
les transports, les fêtes
du Nouvel an chinois risquent de
se traduire par une forte hausse
des contaminations et des décès.
Radio-Canada, Montréal,